Guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Tokio. Ich bin zuständig für Sie. Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Bevor wir anfangen, möchte ich Ihnen eine Frage zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, klar.
Wie heißt sie denn?
Ich heiße Frank Pfeiffer.
Frank, noch mein Nachname bitte.
Frank, Pfeiffer.
Pfeiffer.
Pfeiffer, wie es?
PS, PS, EE, double FE, ER.
PS, EE, double FE, ER.
Vielen Dank, Pfeiffer.
Wie heißt sie denn?
Ich bin noch 35.
35.
Oh, sehr jung.
Und wann sind Sie denn?
Am 14. September 1989.
1989.
Und wissen Sie aktuell, wie groß Sie sind und wie viel Sie wiegen?
Wie groß, das weiß ich natürlich, das ändert sich ja eigentlich nicht mehr.
Ich bin 1,84.
1,4.
Steh mal so drin, 1,4,4.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, das schwankt schon eher.
Zeigst du, sind das so 92 Kilo?
92.
Ja, das ist viel.
Vielen Dank, Pfeiffer.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was fühle ich weil, da haben Sie?
Ich habe solche Schmerzen in meinem rechten Bein,
und zwar im Unterschenkel.
Und ja, das beunruhigt mich jetzt so ein bisschen.
Also, der Unterschenkel ist auch angespollen.
Und das ist alles ein bisschen gerührt.
Und die Haut glänzt so ganz doll.
Und das spannt und ja, tut wirklich ziemlich stark weh.
Und das strahlt auch so hinten in die Kniekehle rein.
Ja, und das war mich jetzt ein bisschen unheimlich.
Da dachte ich, da komme ich doch mal eben schnell zu Ihnen.
Sie haben gut gemacht,
zu zu uns kommen.
Hi, Pfeiffer.
Wie ist es, wenn Sie sich die Schmerzen?
Ja, das hat vor zwei Tagen so ein bisschen angefangen.
Aber erst war das nur so, dass das ein ganz bisschen geschwollen war.
Und da habe ich gedacht, naja, gut.
Ich hatte eine lange Autofahrt.
Und klar, da schwellen an die Beine dann schon mal ein kleines bisschen an.
Und das habe ich dann irgendwie gar nicht so ernst genommen.
Aber als das jetzt dann immer wieder so ist,
so ernst genommen, aber als das jetzt dann immer schlimmer wurde,
habe ich gedacht, Mensch, jetzt muss ich mich doch mal drum kümmern.
Okay.
Auch weil das Bein so komisch rot und dick ist.
Wie lange hatte sie Autofahrt?
Wie lange die Autofahrt gedauert hat?
Ja, die hat, ja, wie lange bin ich unter sich?
Ohne Pause, meine sie vier Stunden, beispielsweise.
Ja, das waren sieben Stunden.
Ich habe mal kurz eine Pause zum Kaffee trinken gemacht,
aber eigentlich bin ich so ziemlich durchgefahren, ja.
Ja, verstehe.
Und wie stark diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkalafon 0 bis 10?
Wobei 0 kann Schmerzen, 10 sehr starke Schmerzen.
Ich kann das nicht gut sagen.
Wie stark?
Also, ja, die sind schon da,
die sind jetzt nicht unerträglich,
sonst wäre ich ja früher gekommen.
Aber, puh, vielleicht so 4, 5 oder 5, 6.
Ja, also wenn ich das Bein ein bisschen hochlege,
dann ist es ein klein wenig besser.
Aber wenn ich auftrete, dann tut es schon mehr weh, ja.
Dann vielleicht eher so bei 5 bis 6.
Und mich schreiben Sie bitte diese Schmerzen.
Sind diese Schmerzen stechende, beinahe drückende?
Ich würde mal sagen, es drückt, es drückt ziemlich, ja.
Brennen tut es eigentlich nicht.
Nee, es drückt ziemlich heftig da in den Beinen, ja.
Okay, drückende.
Haben Sie früher eigentlich beschwerden?
Nee, also ich meine, ich habe natürlich,
weil ich einen Steeberuf habe, ich arbeite im Verkauf.
Muss ich viel stehen und ich habe so ein bisschen Krampfadern,
da hat man schon mal ein bisschen dicke Beine, ja.
Aber dass ich jetzt solche Schmerzen hatte, das kenne ich nicht, nein.
Haben Sie beidseitige Krampfadern, beide Beine?
Ja, das hat man irgendwann mal festgestellt, ja.
Wurden Sie wegen dieser Krampfadern operiert oder Medikamente bekommen?
Nein, nein, das weiß ich, mein Hausarzt hat dann nur gesagt,
ja, Sie müssen ein bisschen aufpassen, weil Sie eben Steeberuf haben und so.
Aber bisher habe ich da nichts gegen getan.
Herr Pfeiffer, ich möchte fragen, Trauma oder Verletzungen an Beinen
oder Insektenstichen, Zäckenbis, habe Sie schon bemerkt?
Insektenbis, nee, ich glaube, Zäcken ist noch zu früh insekten.
Nein, also, unten eine Verletzung, eine Verletzung habe ich eigentlich auch nicht gehabt.
Ich bin ja nur, was war es ich, ich war auf einer Modemesse
und da bin ich rumgelaufen und dann bin ich eben nach Hause gefahren
und die Fahrt hat lange gedauert, aber eine Verletzung habe ich nicht gehabt.
Nein.
Haben Sie Herzschweche?
Herzschweche habe ich eigentlich nicht, nein, nein.
Herzschweche?
Also, was ich jetzt habe, ich bin noch zusätzlich total erkältet,
weil es war so warm im Auto und dann habe ich mal die Klimaanlage angemacht
und jetzt habe ich wieder so eine total verstopfte Nase
und ich habe aber so eine chronische Nebenhöhlenentzündung, ja.
Das habe ich immer wieder und das ist so eine Schwachstelle
und ja, da hat es mich jetzt auch wieder erwischt
und ich merke, dass ich auch so Kopfschmerzen habe
und so, aber mit den Beinen...
Sie sind Kopfschmerzen und Nebenhöhlen entzündet wegen einer Klimaanlage?
Ja, ich hatte im Auto halt, weil das draußen warm war,
dann hatte ich halt die Klimaanlage angemacht.
Ich habe es fieber.
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber also,
tatsächlich habe ich in der Nacht ordentlich geschwitzt,
aber ich bin nicht auf die Idee gekommen, zu messen.
Fühlen Sie sich fieblich oder warm?
Nein, ich bin ja nicht so doll.
Nein, so dieses übliche, wenn man verschnuppt ist, ja.
Sie haben keine Fieber, keine...
Ich habe mich nicht gemessen,
aber in der Nacht habe ich geschwitzt, das weiß ich.
Wie seit wann hatten Sie Schwitzen?
Wie viele Nächte habe ich schon geschwitzt,
das ist jetzt eigentlich auch seit zwei Tagen,
dass ich nachts zwischen ruhig mal aufgewacht bin
und gemerkt habe, ich bin ganz verschwitzt.
Ich stehe.
Und leidung Sie unter Schütterfrost?
Schütterfrost hatte ich nicht mehr.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nein, übel ist mir nicht,
aber was ich gemerkt habe,
mir schmeckt das Essen jetzt diese Tage nicht so gut.
Aber das hängt natürlich auch mit dieser Erkältung zusammen.
Wenn man so verstopft ist in der Nase,
dann schmeckt man ja auch nichts.
Deswegen habe ich auch keinen Appetit,
aber ich versuche viel zu trinken.
Warum Sie Erkältung?
Ihnen ist es nicht.
Warum Sie Ihnen ist es nicht?
Ich habe gesagt, ich bin jetzt erkältet
wegen der Klimaanlage im Auto.
Jetzt, ja.
Deswegen sind die Kieferhöhe und Stirnhöhe...
Ja, Nase neben Höhen.
Aber ich verstehe.
Sie haben keine Erbrechen, oder?
Ich musste mich nicht übergeben.
Nein, Erbrochen habe ich nicht.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Schwindelig ist mir eigentlich auch nicht.
Haben Sie Hüste?
Hüste? Nein, noch nicht.
Mal gucken, vielleicht kommt es noch,
aber warum habe ich keinen Schnupfen?
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasser oder Stuhlgang?
Nein, Gott sei Dank.
Ich muss natürlich ein bisschen aufpassen beim Essen,
sagen wir mal so.
Ich habe eine bekannte Unverträglichkeit gegen Gluten,
aber wenn ich praktisch glutenfrei esse,
habe ich auch keine Bauchprobleme.
Sonst, wenn ich natürlich daran nicht drauf achte,
dann habe ich Bauchschmerzen und Durchfall.
Aber wenn ich da vernünftig esse, habe ich das gut im Griff.
Gut zu wissen.
Herr Pfeiffer, Sie haben keine Wasserlassenprobleme?
Keine Probleme beim Wasserlassen? Nein.
Keine Probleme beim Wasserlassen.
Ich möchte fragen, seit zwei Tagen bestehen die Plöstisch-Bestehende.
Das ist, äh, langsam haben diese Probleme die Schmerzen.
Langsam oder habe ich plötzlich angefangen?
Ich habe gemerkt, dass das Bein so ein bisschen dick war
und dann hat, ich würde sagen, das hat langsam angefangen
und ist dann schmer geworden.
Okay, schlafen Sie gut?
Na jetzt die letzten Nächte habe ich nicht gut geschlafen,
aber normalerweise schlafe ich meistens ganz gut.
Welche Probleme einschlafen oder durch Schlafprobleme leiden Sie unter?
Also normalerweise schlafe ich gut.
Ich leide nicht unter Einschlafproblemen.
Aber jetzt in der letzten Nacht hatte ich halt Schmerzen
und bin deswegen zwischendurch aufgewacht
und aufweilig geschwitzt haben, ne?
Ist Ihnen in der Zeit gewiss Verlust aufgefallen?
Nee, also so viel ich weiß, ist mein Gewicht immer stabil.
Stabil, gut.
Und leiden Sie an chronisch Erkrankungen
außer diese Kraftadern, Sinusitis oder Kopfschmerzen.
Die andere Bluthochdruck, Blutzucker.
Also, was bei mir noch bekannt ist,
da muss ich natürlich auch so ein bisschen drauf aufpassen.
Ich habe eine Schildrösenerkrankung.
Und da muss ich natürlich regelmäßig Medikamente nehmen.
Das ist so eine Hashimoto-Tereolitis.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie diese?
Ja, das hat man vor fünf Jahren mal festgestellt.
Ganz überraschend.
Ich wusste gar nicht, wie mir geschah.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Bitte?
Ich nehme nämlich die Ultrux.
Ja, also und das wird dann immer mal wieder geprüft,
ob die Werte in Ordnung sind.
Also im Augenblick nehme ich halt Ultrux 100
und nehme da morgens eine Tablette.
Und damit sieht es im Augenblick ganz gut aus.
Okay, nur 100 Tablette, nur morgens nehmen Sie.
Genau.
Gut.
Und sonst noch andere Krankheiten?
Ne, also das ist das eigentlich ja.
Nehmen Sie die andere Medikamente regelmäßig
oder bei Bedarf ein?
Ja, also ich nehme gegen diese Nebenhöhlen-Entzündung
und so, damit sich das löst, nehme ich immer Gelomirtol.
Das sind so Kapseln.
Das hilft mir eigentlich immer ganz gut.
Ja, und wenn ich mal wirklich starke Schmerzen habe,
so dass ich Kaufschmerzen habe und das Gefühl habe,
ich kann so nicht gut arbeiten oder so.
Könnten Sie bitte diese Tablette Kapseln bestabieren?
Gel-m-e-tol-g-e-l-y-l-o.
Und dann m-y-r-t-o-l.
Das heißt das glaube ich, Gelomirtol.
Das ist so ein Möhrenextrakt.
Gelomirtol.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Und sonst noch andere Medikamente ein?
Wie gesagt, wenn ich mal starke Kopfschmerzen habe
oder so, dann nehme ich auch meinen Asterofen oder Ibuprofen.
Aber jetzt habe ich jetzt noch nichts genommen.
Okay, Ibuprofen.
Bei Bedarf.
Diese Medikamente haben Sie selbst bekommen
oder Ihren Hausarzt für Sie verabschieden?
Das olze Rockskrieg ist natürlich über meinen Hausarzt
und der Gelomirtol.
Manchmal verschreibt er mir das,
aber eigentlich muss ich das selber bezahlen
in der Apotheke, weil die Krankenkasse das nicht bezahlt.
Und deswegen kaufe ich es mir dann eben auch auf selber,
wenn ich es brauche.
Okay, ein High-Pypha.
Aber selbst Medikation hat manchmal gefährlich.
Sie sollten Ihren Hausarzt haben.
Ist manchmal gefährlich.
Deswegen sollten Sie diese langzeitige Tableten
oder Kopfschulen Ihren Hausarzt fragen.
Wie gesagt, er hat mir die ja empfohlen
und hat sie mir auch hin und wieder verschrieben.
Er hat sie mir ja auch verschrieben.
Aber wie gesagt, ich muss da ja nicht jedes Mal hinlaufen,
wenn ich die auch so bekommen kann.
Versteht. Und rachen Sie ja frei vor?
Seit fünf Jahren rauch ich zum Glück nicht mehr nach.
Ja, bravo.
Aber ich habe auch richtig viel geraucht.
Warum haben Sie angefangen, weniger mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören?
Gibt es eine Grund?
Eigentlich habe ich gemerkt, dass es teuer ist
und dass es auch gut ohne geht.
Super.
Wie viele Jahre und wie viele Zigaretten haben Sie geraucht?
Ja, so von 20 bis 30, kann man sagen.
Aber ich habe auch nie viel geraucht,
vielleicht so 10 Zigaretten am Tag.
Also auch nicht wirklich viel.
10 Zigaretten am Tag.
Und zinkt sie Alkohol?
Ja, also ich trinke schon gerne Abend zum Feierabend
ein Glas Wein oder im Sommer,
das ist richtig heiß, auch gerne meine Flasche Bier.
Ein Glas Wein.
Zinken Sie ein Glas Wein, jeder Feierabend?
So ungefähr, ja, also ziemlich regelmäßig am Abend.
Und auch ein Glas Bier, oder?
Alternativ, entweder das eine oder das andere.
Oder, oder, verstehe.
Wie viele Tage müssen Sie arbeiten?
Was meinen Sie Feierabend?
Sechs Tage müssen Sie arbeiten.
Ja, und am Wochenende trinkt man natürlich auch,
wenn man ein bisschen gesellig ist mit anderen Leuten zusammen
oder so, oder mal ein schönes Essen hat,
dann trinkt man natürlich auch gerne mal ein Glas Wein
oder auch zwei.
Ich meine, Sie sollten ab und zu auch Samstag arbeiten.
Ja, natürlich muss ich Samstag arbeiten, wir haben ein Geschäft.
Und da, das ist sechs Tage in der Woche geöffnet, Gott sei Dank, ja.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht per se,
es ist eine routine Frage.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Ne, also, ja, was weiß ich in meinen jungen Jahren,
habe ich das natürlich mal probiert.
Da habe ich mal ein bisschen haschisch geraucht
und ja, aber das habe ich nie lange gemacht.
Mhm, okay.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, ich habe mir vor acht Jahren, das ist das her,
da hatte ich mal einen Fahrradunfall
und da habe ich mir den Oberarm kompliziert gebrochen
und das ist operiert worden
und das ist auch damals dann mit Platine oder Schrauben
mit Zuletplattchen gemacht worden
und das Metall ist dann eben auch nachher wieder rausgekommen.
Gut.
Und hat es Komplikationslos durchgeführt, diese Oper?
Hat es Komplikationen gegeben oder war die Operation Komplikationslos?
Ja, die begab es eigentlich, keine Probleme,
das war zum Glück alles, ist das gut gelaufen
und ich habe jetzt keine Beschwerden mehr in dem Linken nach.
Gut.
Und sonst noch andere Operationen?
Ne, sonst bin ich noch nicht operiert worden.
High-fiveer, leben Ihre Alter noch?
Ja, die leben beide noch, ja, die sind ja oft noch nicht so weit.
Gibt es irgendwelche Probleme oder Krankheit?
Ja, also bei meinem Vater, der hatte vor drei Monaten
eine Krebsoperation und der hat einen künstlichen Dharma-Ausgang bekommen,
aber eigentlich hat er sich jetzt ganz gut erholt von der Operation.
Ja, das ist ein Dharma-Ausgang, oder?
Ja, genau.
Okay, künstliche.
Und wie ist Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter, die ist eigentlich relativ fit,
die hat nur ein bisschen Probleme mit ihren Kniegelenken.
Welche?
Bitte?
Welche Knie?
Beide.
Und welche Probleme hat sie?
Ja, die sind halt irgendwie verschlissen, da hat sie Knorpelschäden oder so was.
Und da muss sie halt ein bisschen aufpassen.
Gut.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich bin Einzelkind.
Gut.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Gluten, Sie vertragen Sie nicht Gluten,
aber haben Sie allergien?
Ja, ich habe noch eine Allergie auf Novalgien, das darf ich auch keinen Fall nehmen.
Mhm.
Welch, wie äußer sich da raus?
Ja, also da kriege ich tatsächlich dann keine Luft
und ich kriege auch einen Hautausschlag, also so ein grötetes Gesicht und so.
Und dann bleibt mir die Luft weg, also das muss ich wirklich vermeiden.
Deswegen müssen Sie im Krankenhaus eine allergische Schock?
Nein, so richtig, Schock war das nicht, aber wir haben das gemerkt
und dann habe ich halt Antihistamin bekommen und dann hat sich das wieder gegeben.
Also das war, aber es war eben so, dass man mir gesagt hat,
Sie dürfen das auf keinen Fall nochmal nehmen.
Okay, natürlich.
Bitte keine Sorge.
Seit wann haben Sie Novalgien-Allergie?
Oh, das hat man irgendwie schon früh festgestellt, so,
äh, vielleicht so, als ich 20 war oder so.
Mhm.
Dann ist noch andere Allergie?
Nee, Gott sei Dank nicht.
Okay.
Herr Pfeiffer, Sie haben, Sie arbeiten als Alkawiefer, oder?
Hä?
Welche, ähm, was machen Sie, Berufich?
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe einen Stehberuf, ich arbeite im Verkauf.
Wir haben ein Geschäft, ein Modegeschäft.
Modegeschäft, Verkaufsach.
Nein, also ich bin, ich bin der Geschäftsinhaber, ja, das ist meine Firma,
die habe ich von den Eltern übernommen, aber ich muss mich halt darum kümmern,
ich arbeite selber mit im Verkauf.
Okay, Sie sind satzstandiger.
Ja.
Und deswegen, Sie haben viel Stress vielleicht da.
Da habe ich noch Stress, ja, natürlich, ja.
Wie ist Ihre Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Meine Frau arbeitet auch mit in der Firma, ja.
Wohnen Sie mit Ihrem Frau zusammen?
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ein Sohn haben wir, ja.
Ist er gesund?
Der Sohn ist gesund, ja, ja.
Gut.
Der ist auch noch klein, ja.
Ja, siehst du, Frau Steine, ich gehe gegen auch Corona.
Ja, das war ja seinerzeit wichtig, weil wir eben auch viel Kontakt hatten
und so, da habe ich mich natürlich impfen lassen, ja.
Gut.
Und treiben Sie Sport regelmäßig?
Ja, also ich gehe schon regelmäßig Fahrrad fahren am Wochenende
und in Urlaub mache ich auch ein bisschen mehr Sport.
Aber dass ich jetzt zu jedem Abend irgendwie in die Mugigude gehe,
so etwas, da habe ich keine Zeit dafür.
Und Sie sind in nächster Zeit ins Ausland gereist?
Ja, ich war tatsächlich in Italien zu dieser Modemesse da.
Mhm, wann war das?
Naja, aber ich bin vor zwei Tagen zurückgefahren.
Okay, vor zwei Tagen.
Verstehe.
Diese Reise dauert in Gefahr sieben Stunden, Sie haben.
Ja, also ich habe zwischen Ruhestationen gemacht,
aber die letzte Etappe hat eben sieben Stunden gedauert, ja.
Okay.
Hi, hi, ich bin fertig.
Müssten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nee, ich habe Ihnen ja ganz viel erzählt.
Ich möchte ja nur wissen, dass man gegen diese Beinschmerzen machen kann
und woher das kommt und ja, was ich tun kann,
damit ich wieder arbeiten kann, ja.
Mhm, hi, hi, hi, ich kann gerade natürlich nicht 100%
Ihre Krankheit erklären.
Aber ich denke, Ihre Beine gefestene Probleme haben.
Entweder eine.
Moment, ich denke, Sie haben Probleme mit Ihren Beinen gefest.
Beine gefest?
Mhm, und deswegen, es wäre besser, wenn Sie bei uns behalten.
Ich muss da zu näher aufgenommen werden?
Ja, es wäre besser.
Aha, okay, und was machen Sie dann hier mit mir?
Bitte schön.
Was machen Sie da mit mir hier?
Ja, während dieser Untersuchung für Sie zuerst natürlich ein bisschen Blut abnehmen,
dann werde ich Ihren Beinen mit Ultraschall darstellen.
Ja, so noch.
Das wäre eine Ultraschall-Untersuchung der Beine durchführen.
Ja.
Mhm.
Was kann man da sehen?
Ja, mit Hilfe dieser Ultraschall können wir Ihren Beine gefesten ganz genau darstellen,
damit die...
Wir können Ihre Beine gefeste genau darstellen, ja?
Mhm.
Können Ihre Beine gefeste genau darstellen, um die...
einen Verengung auszuschließen.
Ah, ja, okay, das könnte sein, dass da eine Verengung ist, sagen Sie.
Mhm.
Deswegen, Ihren Beinen Verbresserung und Yürötungen und Schwillungen und Schmerzen haben.
Und wir werden für Sie eine Blutverdünne.
Und ja, ja, also Sie sagen auf alle Fälle, ich muss hier bleiben,
aber ja nicht die ganze Nacht, oder?
Ja, meine wegen, ich denke, es wäre besser,
circa eine Blutverdünne bei US-Stationäre aufnehmen.
Okay, ja, da muss ich noch zu Hause anrufen,
dass meine Frau mir noch Sachen bringt.
Aber okay, wenn es unbedingt sein muss, ja.
Gut, dann wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Ja, sofort, ich werde Ihren Bitterparameter darstellen,
Bitterparameter überprüfen,
Ihren beiseitigen Beinen untersuchen durchführen.
Natürlich, beiseitige Beinen und Susan Puls abtasten.
Wir werden an beiden Beinen die Puls testen.
Ja.
Danach, ja, wir werden so schnell wie möglich eine Blutverdünne,
wie Sie, wie Sie, Ihren Armen wenden.
Mit den Armen wenden? Ich habe es an den Beinen.
Ja, ich werde für Sie Ihren Armen Zugang öffnen.
Ein Zugang legen?
Ja, ich lege, ja.
Ich lege.
Danach diese Spritze, diese Blutverdünne,
werde ich Ihren Zugang spritzen.
Aha, okay.
Ja, Sie werden schon wissen, was Sie machen.
Gut, ist das nicht gefährlich?
Wenn Sie nach Hause ohne Therapie gehen,
natürlich ist es gefährlich.
Nein, ich meine jetzt diese Spritze,
von der Sie sprechen, ist die nicht gefährlich?
Nein, das ist, Sie sind in Krankenhaus,
in Krankenhaus und wie diese Spritze mache ich selber.
Okay.
Deswegen, kein Problematisch.
Gut, okay.
Vielen Dank.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch an der Frage?
Ich habe eigentlich eine Frage.
Haben Sie auch Herzrasen oder Atemnot dabei?
Nein, das habe ich zum Glück nicht.
Nein, aber Sie haben nach Herzproblemen gefragt,
aber Sie haben tatsächlich nicht nach Akuten,
Herzproblemen oder Atemnot gefragt.
Das ist schon richtig.
Möchte noch jemand irgendwas wissen?
Könnte mir als Herzgespräch anfangen.
Ich denke, keine Fragen.
Okay.
Ja, ich versuche.
Gut, dann schießen Sie los.
Sehr geehrte Frau Obererzen, ich habe einen neuen Patient,
den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Ich habe einen neuen Patientin, den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Patientin, ja, Patientin.
Es geht um Frank Pfeiffer.
Er ist 35 Jahre alt, 1,84 m groß, 92 kg.
Herr Pfeiffer startete sich bei uns vor Aufgrund seit
2 Tagen, 5tein, langsamen, langsamer Zunehmung,
rücken, rücken, rechth Seite,
Beinschmerzen mit Unterschenkel ausstrahlen.
Die Beinschmerzen strahlen in den Unterschenkel aus?
Nein, die Strahlen knikele.
Nein, nein. Die Strahlen in knikele.
Also er schmerzt im rechten Unterschenkel und die Strahlen in die Knikele aus.
Die Schmerzinterstate liegt beim Hochlagerung 4 bis 5,
beim Auftretzen 5 bis 6 auf der normalischen Skala.
Er habe beidseitige Beine, Barikose, darüber hinaus klackte er über Rötungen,
glänzende Beine, glänzende Spannungsgefühl und glänzende Haut.
Die Fragen nach Düstnö, das Probleme, wurden fernleit.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig bis obgenannte Symptome und seit 2 Tagen nächtliche Hyperhydros
und wegen nicht mehr bedingte Technik somnä.
Er hat gerade eine Gellomytholk.
Er ist nicht so gut. Er leidet auch Haeschmottoteroiditis seit 5 Jahren.
Er ist eine Abdominalschmerz.
Er ist eine Anamnese, sein Vater, sein Vater hat eine Kolonkarsinom für 2 Monaten.
Er wurde operiert und hat gerade Kolonkarsinom.
Er hat seine Mutter, aber die Leidung unter Konarthros.
Er ist ein Patient. Er ist selbstständig. Er hat eine Mode geschafft.
Er ist ein Patient. Er ist selbstständig.
Er ist selbstständig.
Er ist selbstständig. Er ist selbstständig.
Er hat mich nur gewundert, dass sie die Historie erst ganz spät erklärt haben.
Sie haben gesagt, er hat sich vorgestellt mit Beinschmerzen und Beinschwellung.
Aber er ist ganz zum Schluss des Arztgesprächs.
Sie haben gesagt, er hatte vorher eine Stunde lange Autofahrt.
Das wäre natürlich vernünftig, das ein bisschen früher zu sagen.
Ich weiß gar nicht.
Noxen haben Sie nicht erwähnt beim Arztgespräch?
Ja, durch die Science-Fifthalle nicht.
Der größte Risikofaktor wäre gewesen, wenn er rauchen würde.
Er hat nicht mehr raucht.
Er ist aufgefallen bei der Familienanamnese.
Der Vater hatte vor zwei Monaten einen Damenkrebs.
Den Damenkrebs hatte er, also den Skolankarzinon.
Das hatte er bestimmt schon länger.
Aber vor drei Monaten ist er operiert worden.
Er war kurz davor festgestellt.
Man muss aufpassen mit den Aussagen, wie man das formuliert.
Die Erkrankung hat man vielleicht vor einem Vierteljahr, halben Jahr diagnostiziert.
Die Behandlung hat vor drei Monaten stattgefunden, in Form einer Operation.
Man muss das auch richtig formulieren.
Er ist vor drei Monaten wegen eines Skolankarzinons operiert worden.
Er hat einen Anuspreter bekommen.
Was wir schon im Gespräch gleich gemerkt haben,
das ganze Bein hat ihm nicht wie, sondern es tut ihm nur der rechte Unterschenkel weh.
Und die Schmerzen strahlen ins Knie aus.
Was wir nicht nachgefragt haben, ob der Fuß geschwollen ist,
ob ihm das aufgefallen ist, ob die Schwellung über den Knöchel geht.
Was sie nicht im Arztgespräch erwähnt haben,
das war die Geschichte, dass sie wohl nach Trauma gefragt haben,
aber dass er das verneint hat.
Das haben sie nicht erwähnt.
Ich fand es eigentlich schön im Gespräch, dass sie es gefragt haben.
Aber wäre dann auch schön gewesen, wenn sie es auch im Arztgespräch
wiedergeben, dass sie gefragt haben.
Können wir diese Briefe für die Korrigation korrigieren?
Sie können mir den Brief gerne schicken.
Schicken Sie ihn so, wie Sie ihn spontan schreiben würden,
ohne da jetzt noch groß drüber zu arbeiten.
Wenn Sie den noch durch ein großes Korrekturprogramm laufen lassen,
dann ist er nicht mehr echt.
Schicken Sie mir ihn mit in Fehlern, dann kann ich den ehrlich bewerden.
Papier schreiben, oder direkt Papier schreiben.
Dann habe ich es sehr schnell zu korrigieren,
weil ich es nur praktisch auf dem Computer habe.
Einfach ist es, wenn Sie mir eine PDF Datei schicken
oder ein Word-Dokument, dann kann ich das hier bei mir auf dem iPad
transformieren und dann sehen Sie auch die Korrekturen.
Sonst muss ich, wenn Sie mir das vorhand schicken, das geht,
aber dann muss ich Ihnen eine E-Mail schreiben oder eine Nachricht schreiben.
Und da steht dann, in zweiten Appte schreiben Sie so und so,
das muss aber so und so heißen.
Das ist natürlich für mich wahnsinnig viel Schreibarbeit.
Und insofern ist es einfacher, wenn Sie es mir als Datei schicken,
dann kann ich es Ihnen mit den Korrekturen zurückschicken
und Sie sehen, dann fahre ich markiert, wo ich etwas geändert habe.
Und ich mache das auch in Klammern, warum ich das geändert habe.
Okay, danke schön.
Ja, aber können Sie gerne machen, Dr. Gündes, macht das.